الشركات الامريكيه الكبرى دخلت على خط
التسويه مع الصين لنزع فتيل الفتنه بين
اكبر اقتصادين في العالم في وقت يحتدم
الصراع بين واشنطن وبيكين زاد من حدته
حادث بالون التجسس الشهير والتوترات حول
شكوك امريكيه بتجسس الصين على واشنطن
والعالم من خلال تيك توك ومع وجود مؤشرات
قليله على المصالحه وبحجه ان للقوى العظمى
مصلحه مشتركه في استمرار التعاون حتى
ايلون ماسك الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تسلا
رحاله في الصين والتقى وزير خارجيتها وهي
احدث عوده لرئيس تنفيذي امريكي كبير الى
الصين والتي اعتبرها الخبراء عاليه
المخاطر في وقت
الامريكيه الصينيه الى اعلى مستوياتها
وعلى كافه الصعد
شركات كبرى سبقت ماسك الى خط المصالحه
كابل و ستاربكس وغيرها في دليل واضح على
حاجه السوق الامريكي الى الصين في النمو
فالمصالح الامريكيه والصينيه يراها
الخبراء لا تنفصل عن بعضها البعض
وبمازل عن توجهات قاده البلدين في اداره
الصراع القائم سيستمر الخصمان بالاعتماد
على بعضهما البعض مهما اشتد الصراع بينهما
مع ادراك كبرى الشركات الامريكيه اهميه
الصين في النمو الاقتصادي العالمي ولعدم
حدوث انفجار كبير كارثي قد يوجه اقتصاد
العالم الى مسار لا تحمد عقبه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات